all right I'm Bob Crane known to some
people who watch television as a
captured World War two pirate on Holden
zero I don't get a chance to do much
flying in real life so agent Lee I like
not to an airbase shoot the breeze with
the professional this trip was a
complete bust a real planer old place is
deserted
nobody
nothing
this used to be the home of the Air
National Guard a busy place too
especially on weekend now I look at it
what happened is this outfit went to war
like a lot of other Air National Guard
op that's all over the country
these guys look familiar
they oughta be seen them before in your
local bank the grocery store at the
hospital classroom
the courtroom maybe in your own home
at the moment these men are out
fulfilling military obligations at bases
all over the globe but they're only
temporary warriors permanent citizens
they're your friends friends and
neighbors the people you know
January 25th 1968 the president
mobilizes 11 Air National Guard
squadrons before the 9,000 men
International development's of suddenly
increased the nation's total
requirements for airpower the Air Guard
is being called upon for help there was
nothing unusual in every war in our
history citizens have been asked to
abandon their peacetime activities and
take up arms this is one of the
responsibilities of citizenship but
rarely have been responded with greater
speed and made the transition more
smoothly
in fact these citizen Airmen are ones
like them have left their homes and jobs
four times in the past 20 years to serve
in times of international emergencies
this is what most air Guardsmen expect
after their call and what is expected of
them within 24 hours more than ninety
nine and a half percent of the men in
the mobilized units report for duty
while their fully trained and ready for
combat the moment they're called up
these men will still take advantage of
the integral between call-up and
deployment to sharpen those skills
rehearse those procedures and practice
those exercises
which may be of the greatest value to
them were ever there set Vietnam South
korea-japan as the deployment date
approaches certain decisions have to be
made a nice problem for a computer those
units alerted for overseas can take
along only about one half of their
personnel but many more than that have
volunteered to go which ones will be
chosen finally the date arrives the
selected units are scheduled to the part
at intervals of about two weeks the
first to go is the 120th Tactical
Fighter Squadron
at Buckley Field Denver Colorado the
equipment goes first spare engines to
replace any which might wear out or be
destroyed ground vehicles for use on the
flightline
other equipment and tools to repair and
if necessary rebuild engines for
aircraft the ground personnel are a
vital part of the outfit
they'll have to be set up and waiting at
the first stop to service the incoming
fighter planes so they guide with the
equipment the c-141 Starlifter 15 tons
of men and equipment in each of the huge
aircraft
the fighter pilots get their briefing
from their commanding officer Lieutenant
Colonel Robert cherry the upcoming
flight will be made in three hops Hawaii
ROM and Vietnam with frequent in-flight
refuelings on the long hops technically
the exact destination is still
classified
not until they arrive in South Vietnam
will their exact destination be made
public but their families have a pretty
good idea where these men are headed
later these same goodbyes are repeated
by other Guard units at the Sioux City
Albuquerque Niagara Falls Columbus Ohio
Little Rock Reno Wichita but don't get
the impression that all the men are
going in units to the Far East actually
more than half the guards been mobilized
are filling individual assignments at
some 86 flying bases at home and abroad
for some men this is the third time
they've said goodbye and going off to
war but it doesn't get any easier with
repetition
no one knows how much longer his luck
will hold a day a week a month a year
some of these citizens may find out the
hard way
it's the Strategic Air commands flying
service stations that make it possible
for the fighter pilots to carry their
own planes across the thousands of miles
of ocean once they're airborne each of
the kc-135 tankers quickly gathers up
and takes under its wings some five or
six of the fighter planes and mothers
then the rest of the way across the
Pacific in flight refuelling is a
delicate and precise operation yet
because of the relatively short range of
Fighters it must be repeated several
times by each pilot in order to span the
Pacific the first stop for all units is
Hickam Air Force Base light the ground
crews which were sent ahead are ready
and waiting the service the f100 for the
second leg of the journey it's a very
short stopover though the next morning
the tankers and the c-141 lead the way
into the air again
yes 100 stato
rendezvous with their tankers and the
plane is on again alone hours in the
clamp fighter cockpit Sameera branding
but it's not the kind of parade that
anyone wants to drop out of finally the
120th arrives at its designated base in
Vietnam fan Lang on hand to greet the
incoming pilots of the base commander
and general women mobile then commander
of all air force units in Vietnam it's
been a textbook movement the 120th is
arrived on schedule three days after
leaving Denver with all 20 planes in
fact ready for action the same record is
achieved by Iowa's 174th Tactical
Fighter Squadron it flies into Q cap to
explode
for the guard units one from Albuquerque
the other from Niagara Falls fluent or
too dry well together these four
squadrons ferry 80 short-range fighter
planes across 12,000 miles of open ocean
all but four planes making the trip on
schedule
not bad for citizens turned Airmen but
getting here is only the beginning their
mission is to assist the active Air
Force in supporting the American and
South Vietnamese ground forces in some
places there's skepticism about their
ability to perform the dot for long
within a few days of arrival after a
short period of theater indoctrination
each squadron is ready for action
since the Coloradans are the first to
arrive they're the first to see action
before long each squadron is averaging
more than 20 combat missions a day the
skills learned in other wars are coming
in very handy in this way there are no
more doubts about the abilities of these
units but another thing that makes these
air Guardsmen unique is that all of the
pilots with one or two exceptions have
the skill and experience to qualify as
flight leaders they and the 350 fifth
also at Phuket which is composed largely
of Air Guard personnel the other
mobilized units are the equal of any
Tactical Fighter Squadron India
their secret partly suppress the expert
supervision of such experienced NCOs as
who chief charles moore of the Colorado
Air National Guard
boys I'm concerned with the best I mean
most of us got more than five or six
years in the outfit I say we have is
mostly technician average about 10 to 15
years experience but it's also
first-class leadership provided by such
experienced pilots as Lieutenant Colonel
Gordon rung the CEO of the Sioux City
Iowa Air National Guard that is why you
keep developing you get down to a low
angle you arrange out there where you
can clear that impact area real
but even the constant pressure of combat
in the 12-hour workday which is standard
in Vietnam still need a little time for
other things
some serious and some not so serious
there's no doubt about it Vietnam in a
long way from long but there are ways to
keep in touch and for those who want
their communication to be even more
personal than a letter there are means
to provide that too hi ru hey facilities
are available for use in both directions
all I can say is honeyed I sure do miss
you you'll be interested to know that
your brother penis back at school now
and doing very well take care of
yourself and the baby can you imagine
that home of course is at the back of
everybody's mind in every war this one
is no exception I want you to know he's
doing the song of you relative you don't
know okay I wanna go
my my
you
you
most of these air Guardsmen volunteered
to go to combat and though they play the
game in the songfest not many want to go
home before they finish the god they
came here to do
the war in Vietnam is really two wars
one being fought with bombs and bullets
and run with hands and hearts the Air
Guard units are actively engaged in both
wars
these men are the 174th and the 355th
the poop hat devote their free time
helping the villagers of nearby fund
done they build the homes destroyed by
the rockets and mortars of the Vietcong
other air Guardsmen such as flight
surgeons major Thurmond ABS major Carl's
Shushi spend as much time as possible
trying to repair the damage war always
brings to the weak and helpless doctors
you see this little boy that I was
telling you about the other day about
two weeks ago we picked him up in the
pennant at song town we've been able to
get rid of three of the parasites I'm
still having considerable difficulty
with his heart and lungs
who
after everything that you haven't
already found in a 50 thing that used
our program and do the journey alright
your wheel will keep on with that then
and I like to know how we get along with
burn explain to him now that you'll be
going home in about four days
whatever the air Guardsmen do in their
spare time however the reason for being
in Vietnam is to support the Allied
ground forces in their battles with the
Viet Cong and the North Vietnamese
averaging more than 20 missions a day it
isn't long before the 120 minute fan
rang the first of the Air Guard
squadrons to begin fighting approaches
an important milestone it's 1,000
mission this mission is a two plane
strike against an enemy unit opposing an
American military force in the south
leading the mission is Major John L
France in civilian life a practicing
attorney in Denver first he gets a
weather briefing as you can no longer
call her you might later rain showers
and thundershowers there's one good
sized one still up to 20,000 feet
dissipating with Roncalli
scattered spread running to the point of
around 1,000 1,500 feet weather
gentlemen to the 4-carat força aérea is
expected to you know demonstrate a few
around 1500 then comes an intelligence
briefing where he learns everything
known about the combat situation in the
target area in the the hang area we have
reported contacts to the north to the
west to the south all around the area
the villagers report
considerable numbers of PC moving into
battery and working further south and to
Cora dark back again quiet for a change
no rockets no murders same way with octo
con to them and Pleiku moving further
down banding to still forever three were
on some action to the west troops in
contact out here
we haven't any results of what happened
not there but apparently we're on the
winning edge Major William his plan for
their mission 30 seconds from the other
direction
dr. right past and make a left break and
they will be in the however not even the
most careful planning and attention to
detail
can we move all chance of unforeseen
developments
the unexpected is almost routine on
these missions so they're never boring
flying over Vietnam is much the same as
flying over the United States had the
same soft unreality the land and roles
are the same pattern of rivers and
fields and forests but there is a
difference you're very much aware that
down below a war is going on that men
are fighting and dying those hills and
forests are not as innocent as they seem
nearing the target they pick up the
voice of the forward air controller in
his observation plane above the area
Oh
mission accomplished
return to base
one thousand missions that's only a
beginning of course before they complete
their tours in Vietnam
each Air Guard squadron will have
multiplied that figure by six or seven
still it merits some sort of celebration
on every one of those missions someone
risked his life
right that works
come on John yeah
congratulations here's to one thousand
one thousand
come on I just went off the wagon yeah
real good mission always good
congratulate you here before you get
there
we're looking forward to the second
round
right
on the occasion people hosted this ever
since we got here and I still while I
was in today asked the priest on the
bike and I think it's completely out of
hand the way you're gonna think I care
about so how about 136 14 yeah there's
no doubt that some of these men are
heroes some of their work there was only
one word heroic they've been asked to do
a job a hot sweaty uncomfortable job for
the most part and they're doing it to
the very best of their ability
when the call came they responded
willingly many at great personal
sacrifices because they recognize their
obligations as air Guardsmen and
American citizens their pride in their
units and their devotion to duty are
apparent in everything they do when
these men packed up their gear and flew
off to war they left some pretty big
gaps in the economic and social life of
their community when they returned to
fill these gaps they'll bring with them
the same good sense the same dedication
to duty the same resourcefulness the
same sense of responsibility which makes
them such valuable members of our armed
forces low-angle keep your range out
there where you can where that impact
their your real good
so that I'll be going by hopefully with
the left brake and you can land on in 30
seconds from the other direction
after I passed and make a left brake and
it will be in the butterfly pattern and
we'll keep doing this part that like
they're driving planning that you
haven't already found American if you've
got programming through the journey
alright your will will keep on with that
and and I like to know how we get along
while I'm concern over the best I mean
most of us got more than five or six
years in the outfit I say we have is
most of the technician average about 10
to 15 years experience why shouldn't
they be the best what else would you
expect of your friends and neighbors the
people you know
you